so proud let me beatbox in front of the
Planned Parenthood yeah I got murder on
my mind the fact that it's celebrated
that that murdering children especially
in late term pregnancies is celebrated
that people are so proud of themselves
from mutilating a fetus is just it it
blows my mind and I don't think that you
need to be pro-life to even take that
and you said late term pregnancy yeah a
lot of abortions do not happen I made
the distinction I made the distinction
specifically because lots of people
still celebrate there are people who
when the laws were passed actually here
in New York they said yes great yes I
love them but you need to ask about what
are people celebrating right they're
celebrating access we're not celebrating
any kids like that's that's why we'll
see this one here's the thing when we're
talking about access to reproductive
health and to abortion rights right into
being pro-choice
listen that's your body you do you the
child of your society as I go a baby
it's so scary for me to hear people
calling like guns the biggest equalizer
for women but taking their choices away
from them at a policy level
um why is that having a gun is an
equalizer it is having rights is an
equalizer yeah
and in this country 41 forms the
policies that are pushed to continue
perpetuating patriarchy and anti-women
um like taking the autonomy away from
women it is heartbreaking to see women
pushing that propaganda it's all
brainwashed like brainwashed because I
agree with no idea I have lived deeply
institutionalized I've lived under Islam
I'm not interested in any of that like
there's no like
no I'm not interested in like living
thinking that like women are doing this
really bad thing like in My Religion
abortion is actually allowed if the
woman needs it she's allowed because you
know it's very interesting how like
fundamental America is like this is
nothing very very like very religion
this is a very conservative basic
scientific human rights we're also
talking about people not having access
to abortion clinics where they're doing
them things herself and they die right
we're also talking about women in the
hospital who are pregnant who have
chosen to stay with their pregnancy and
have issues at hospitals and hospitals
that are like oh no we don't do that
listen
for whatever reason you don't need to
explain it to anybody but a lot of times
when we're talking about access to
reproductive health for me I'm thinking
about black indigenous people of color
particularly women and girls who are
working class who do not have even
access to like proper sexual education
it's the oppressive state of saying I
will force you to have a child even
against your own will right especially
when you're thinking about
women and girls who who would be forced
to have these children who are already
living in very traumatized and scared
and scarce situations you want to ask
about barriers that's the barrier right
there women and poverty aren't able to
access the way that rich women are and
no matter what happens rich women are
gonna keep getting abortions and people
or poverty are gonna not and the choice
opening it up the overruling is
marginally affecting
people of color people in poverty way
more than people who are going to get
access to those abortions actually
incorrect your there's actually more
abortions for people in poverty it's
just at a lower rate
why do you think that abortion has been
so tied up in this feminism conversation
it's all just social structure set up
around body so if not all women are able
to have babies but it's about the
barriers and value that we give to these
specific bodies right and so if abortion
happens in a woman's body that's why
this conversation is coming up
can I ask you a question sure you said
um that not all women are able to have
babies or pregnancies are you saying
meaning like an infertility issue a
number of reasons there's all kinds of
reasons that not all women are having
babies Pearl I saw your hand up yeah um
I think women want to sleep around and
not have any consequence for it yeah we
do yeah yeah yeah instead of you know
taking personal accountability and being
on birth control they just want to like
do whatever they want
yeah it almost sounds like you said can
I also ask do you have any care to
empower women or is disempowering women
part of your like stees to see this is
shame insult guilt need to be right okay
why is it important to sleep around
Iraq is very sort of like ah women just
don't want to do this ah women just
don't have this ah women just wanted
this and I wonder why you have so much
like hatred towards women I don't hate
it
I am a woman
like women don't want to work women
don't want to this women want to sleep
around where did you learn these uh
belief systems from because okay the
question was why why does abortion keep
getting brought up 40 of women that have
had abortions have had two or more forty
percent so what does that say to me that
means you're using it as a form of birth
control and they don't track the 60 what
kind of a boy can you let me finish they
don't track the 60 to say who in the
future has abortion so to me it's like
why are they why are they dying so hard
for abortion they want to sleep around
with no consequences even though you
have 41 forms of birth control who does
that benefit I don't think that benefits
women I think actually that benefits men
because it means that men can have sex
with you without consequence it means
that you can sleep with whoever you feel
it great but there are consequences
because women are the ones who get
pregnant and carry babies and give birth
yes because because sex is binary but
please let me finish my point oh God
tricking women into thinking that
aborting a pregnancy terminating
pregnancy is something to be celebrated
when in reality for a lot of women
especially those who are doing it under
duress say that they've been raped or
that you know in in this in the small
circumstances where something really
traumatic has happened to them that's a
medical decision or or say that they're
they're miscarrying and then they have
to you know have a an assisted
termination that's a medical procedure
it's not a celebration of oh look at
this the idea the sort of like moral
setting of that it needs to be rare is
I think the delineation between that's a
medical abortion and that's like a fun
abortion is really interesting because
they're all medical it's all a medical
procedure and so no matter what you're
doing going in there and getting it like
that's not it's it's not like oh you're
only allowed to it's just like you
should just be able to get a medical
procedure done when it's something that
you need done we shouldn't be
desensitized to taking someone's life
that should never be an empowering
factor for a woman I definitely agree in
that like there should be no absolute
thing any woman should do there should
not be an absolute response to incest or
rape or any of these things every woman
should have the choice of if they want
to or not want to carry that child
whether it is
having fun getting raped incest whatever
it is it is I don't glorify and
glamorize abortion I think it's a very
traumatic thing I doubt that if somebody
wants has to do like if they have to do
it they'll do it I don't think that
people are like you know
um doing like half six get the seventh
free and having fun with it
um and I think that like glamorization
and glorification of any side is not
okay did the dog's decision
make anybody here uh sort of rethink
abortion abortion access reproductive
Health Care
it's anti-woman right it's anti it does
not Center people to have that voice for
themselves and their own decisions right
it is a barrier
right yes it's giving more agency to
women because it's moving it back to the
state level so
locally the women tell me what to do
because it doesn't matter
if you take out the the Viewpoint that
life begins at conception which is a
really big defining principle for both
uh the pro-life crowd who very very you
know vehemently believe that and then
obviously a lot of the pro-choice crowd
do not believe that taking that out of
the equation you do not have just
whatever kind of autonomy you want as a
person it's regardless of male or female
you can't just have free run to do
whatever the hell you want that's not
how Society operates at no point at no
point do I have the right to tell anyone
in this room what they should or should
not do with their body but it's not
about your body
okay it's about the kid's body I don't
care what you do with your body
Jordan I saw your hand creep up
the Dobb's decision for me reinforced
how important it is that we approach
these issues from a cultural perspective
because it reinforces something that I
have told many of my colleagues and
peers in the past which is that so long
as you lack a cultural consensus any
issue any issue can become a political
football that can be decided by another
election cycle and so long as there is
no strong consensus I would expect this
to be our reality going forward these
extremely vitriolic and aggressive
conversations until there's another
miraculous consensus that brought about
Roe v Wade but what it more or less
reinforced for me is that we're going to
have more of these difficult
conversations I want to talk about as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick-Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible possible